bonsoir à tous
ah ouais
bonsoir
je vais vous parler du premier vinyle
que j'ai acheté de ma vie c'est un
vinyle du groupe
l'impératrice et dessus il ya un morceau
qui s'appelle parfum theremin qui est
composé à la base un tempo de 120
battements par minute
[Musique]
m
alors la première fois que je les ai
écoutés sur ma platine vinyle je ne
savais pas m'en servir
et j'ai malencontreusement régler la
mauvaise vitesse de lecture
du coup le morceau est passé au ralenti
et c'est plutôt ça que j'ai entendu
[Musique]
c
et j'étais surpris de constater que la
musique me paraissait plus intéressante
à ce thème polacco tempo original une
fois ralenti elle semblait mieux
respirer elle était plus spacieuse plus
aéré plus poétique aussi elle s'ouvrait
un peu comme si on avait poussé les murs
et le même phénomène peut être observée
sur un film zabriskie poynt antonioni 70
les images ralenti révèle une poésie
qu'on ne percevait pas d'abord une sorte
de grâce qui était imperceptible à
l'oeil nu invisible à vitesse réelle
la lenteur révèle des couleurs nouvelles
elle dévoile des mondes encore inaperçu
en somme tout devient magnifique dès
lors qu'on le ralenti non seulement la
musique et les images mais aussi la vie
notre vie nous aussi dans la vie on a
cette capacité d'activer la fonction
ralenti comme sur un magnétoscope
on a ce pouvoir magique et dès lors
qu'on fait cet effort d'attention et
qu'on prend le temps de regarder les
gens il se passe la même chose que pour
la musique de l'impératrice où le film
d'antonioni les instances dilate et ils
nous livrent leurs secrets
regardez bien lorsqu'on a bu son café au
fond de sa tasse ce qui reste
ça ressemble à une carte de géographie
[Musique]
et ce matin sur ma table de petit
déjeuner mammoth de peur ressembler à
une dune de sable
quand on prend le temps
de regarder quelqu'un dans les yeux
de plus près
chaput pile devient une planète
et en regardant autour de soi en prenant
le temps
on y remarque soudain tout ce qui est
beau
[Musique]
ce qui est drôle aussi
un peu comme ces vides et ses vidéos où
on voit des gens tomber au ralenti
les images ralenties
sont plus vivantes
mais plus utile
ils peuvent nous donner 10
solutions à des problèmes
c'est en butant contre la marche à pied
d'un train que le mathématicien poincaré
a trouvé la solution à un problème
mathématique qui le hantait depuis des
semaines
en ralentissant le cours du temps on
crée déjà
on voit autrement
les livres ne font rien d'autre que ça
nous apprendre à voir autrement
à nous passer de réel au ralenti pour
mieux le découvrir vous n'avez jamais
remarqué qu'il y avait comme une bulle
de lenteur qui entoure les gens qui
lisent dans le métro
[Musique]
on dirait qu'ils ne sont pas dans l'âme
espace temps que les autres
on dirait qu'ils vivent quelque chose de
nouveau
lire c'est ça
lire c'est ce passé le real au ralenti
et découvrir des mondes qu'on ne
soupçonnait pas
en lisant on se refait le film
et on revoit des scènes on enlève chaque
détail
marguerite duras a écrit tout un texte
sur la mort d'une louche
où
c'est comme ça que nous voudrions vivre
comme dans un livre
au ralenti attentivement
créativement intensément
inspiré par les gens et les choses
car le monde n'est pas moins bon qu'hier
c'est nous qui allons trop vite
[Applaudissements]